Traduttore: Pietro Gola
Revisore: Giorgio Fighera
Ci hanno in questi periodi ossessionato
con il problema delle fake news.
È il problema della società contemporanea
al punto che è stata eletta
"Parola dell'anno"
dall'Oxford Dictionary per il 2016
e diciamo che in qualche modo
la definizione sta per: "acquisire i fatti
non per via razionale,
ma per una tendenza all'emotività
dell'essere umano."
Lo scopriamo nel 2016.
L'essere umano non è razionale nel 2016.
Come se lo fossimo mai stati.
Torquemada o tante altre storie, insomma,
insegnano come l'essere umano
è ben lontano dall'essere razionale.
Illudersi che l'essere umano sia razionale
è una fake news, per esempio.
Spesso e volentieri la scienza,
quando non capisce le cose,
la scienza evolve per falsificabilità,
un processo di conoscenza
che evolve nel tempo e per errori,
si pone laddove non conosce
con un approccio
che viene chiamato ermeneutico
per farla, perdonatemi il termine,
con le supercazzole
ovvero, noi ci mettiamo lì sopra
e cerchiamo di riempire
un gap informativo
con cose che non sappiamo
e creiamo delle storie,
molto scrittura creativa.
Quello che abbiamo provato
a fare noi invece,
è uscire da questa prassi
e cercare di sfruttare le migliaia,
le tonnellate di dati
che lasciamo ogni giorno online.
Ad esempio, abbiamo idea
di quanti tweet circolino
in ogni secondo?
Quanti post vengono fatti
su Facebook ad ogni minuto?
Siamo nell'ordine dei milioni.
Una quantità impressionante,
un bacino impressionante di informazioni
che possono essere utilizzati da noi,
scienziati, per capire cose
di come funziona la società
ben aldilà della speculazione.
Ovviamente l'approccio mette insieme
sociologia, psicologia sociale,
semiotica, ma non con un approccio
basato sulla intuizione,
bensì sull'approccio empirico.
Ovvero utilizziamo il metodo
delle scienze dure
la fisica, cerchiamo di fare la fisica
dei sistemi sociali.
Partiamo da Mark Zuckerberg,
che nel 2007,
parlando di Facebook, ci dice
che non vuole creare una nuova comunità,
ma vuole soltanto permettere
alle informazioni di circolare
più velocemente.
È un passaggio importante
in qualche modo sta dicendo
che lui sta distruggendo
il sistema informativo in quanto tale.
Toglie di mezzo la mediazione.
Prima eravamo abituati agli esperti
che selezionavano per noi
le informazioni.
La testata giornalistica, la redazione
selezionava i post e le informazioni.
Adesso un gattino,
o una rivoluzione o un colpo di stato,
sui social seguono gli stessi
processi di selezione.
E lì abbiamo un problema:
il nostro cervello,
lo stesso che fa scienza,
evolve per apprendimento,
per approssimazioni
e siamo macchine programmate
per risparmiare energia.
Ad esempio, questa
frase di Albert Einstein:
"Il problema delle citazioni su Internet
è che spesso sono false."
Quanti di voi si sono accorti che
non è Einstein ma quello è Bruno Lauzi?
Per dare un esempio di come
funziona il cervello umano.
Il cervello va per approssimazioni:
capelli bianchi, baffi bianchi,
la frase ci potrebbe stare perché Einstein
appartiene ad una delle persone
che in qualche modo ispira
il nostro modo di pensare,
e quindi va bene, passiamo avanti
passiamo oltre.
E questo passare oltre
ha creato dei problemi non banali.
Ad esempio, eravamo nel luglio del 2015,
alla Quantico University
viene fatta una conferenza stampa
in cui viene detto che sarebbe stata fatta
da lì a poco
una esercitazione antiterrorismo
sul suolo del Texas.
La conferenza stampa parte,
c'è il live tweeting,
i giornalisti che tweettano;
nell'arco di poche ore
quell'esercitazione militare,
l'annuncio dell'esercitazione,
diventa la prova che Obama
sta per fare un colpo di stato
sul suolo degli Stati Uniti.
Ovviamente noi siamo portati a pensare:
"Ma quanto sono imbecilli
quelli che ci sono cascati!"
C'è cascato il governatore del Texas,
che ha allertato la Guardia Nazionale
dicendo di presidiare i confini.
Oppure, quest'altra, il Senatore Cirenga.
Il Senatore Cirenga non esiste.
È una pagina Facebook di cui si ha
Senatore come nome e Cirenga come cognome.
È una bufala inventata
da un cappellaio di Firenze.
Questa bufala ha fatto 35 000 condivisioni
nella prima settimana
e dice che questo fantomatico senatore
ha fatto una proposta
per finanziare i parlamentari
in caso di non-rielezione
con 134 miliardi di euro.
Altro esempio di come
funziona il cervello umano:
134 miliardi di euro, cifra troppo grossa
non riesco ad immaginarla
comunque sì è plausibile,
si inserisce in un contesto di sfiducia
rispetto al governo e alle istituzioni,
passa e diventa virale.
Quest'altra, Pertini, che dice:
"Quando il governo non fa
ciò che il popolo vuole,
va cacciato con mazze e pietre."
Non importa che la fondazione Pertini
l'abbia smentita tantissime volte
è ancora argomento di dibattito
all'interno della politica.
Perché il simbolo incentiva
ad esprimere la sfiducia
nei confronti delle istituzioni.
Qual è il mostro che è qui dietro,
l'assassino?
Il mostro si chiama "Confirmation Bias",
"Pregiudizio di conferma".
È quello che ci porta a dire
che gli altri sono idioti
per affermare la nostra intelligenza,
e soprattutto
è quel meccanismo
che ci porta ad acquisire
le informazioni perché sono coerenti
con la nostra visione del mondo
e a rinnegare quelle che sono a contrasto.
Se sono della Juventus,
crederò tutte le informazioni a supporto
della bellezza
e della forza della squadra;
ignorerò tutte le informazioni a contrasto
sono un giornalista, sono convinto
che le fake news siano un problema,
non importa che è dimostrato
scientificamente che portare le fonti
e cercare di far buon giornalismo
non risolve il problema,
continuerò a credere
che con il fact-checking
posso risolvere il problema
delle fake news.
Il problema è mostruoso.
Tanto che dal 2013 è nominato
tra le minacce globali
nel Global Risk Report
del World Economic Forum
insieme al terrorismo.
Perché un'informazione passa senza filtri,
emerge e impatta sull'opinione pubblica,
come abbiamo visto nel caso
delle vaccinazioni ultimamente,
laddove ci sono stati
due approcci di comunicazione:
uno vigliacco, che è quello che si mette
dalla parte della cattedra e la scienza
diventa sacerdozio,
è quello che non dobbiamo fare,
perché c'è sfiducia.
Tanto che siamo dovuti passare
all'obbligo vaccinale,
tanto è stato l'errore comunicativo;
e tornare invece a capire un pochino
qual è la psicologia
dell'individuo che c'è dietro.
Perché soprattutto c'è questa grande
abbondanza di informazioni false?
Perché siamo esseri umani, siamo limitati
e abbiamo voglia di conoscere,
sete di conoscenza,
sete di conoscenza che a volte è indotta
dal placare l'ansia.
Siamo di fronte alla globalizzazione.
La globalizzazione è un mostro
che non riusciamo
a identificare completamente;
è un qualcosa che in qualche modo
ci riguarda, ma non ne capiamo i confini;
in qualche modo si manifesta
con l'immigrazione,
col fatto che gli stati
non sono in grado di gestire
i flussi economici che si muovono
su scala sovranazionale.
In ogni caso, siamo tutti figli
della stessa scimmia
tendiamo a colmare quei buchi
con idee e narrazioni.
Cerchiamo tutti una narrazione
che in qualche modo dia un senso
alla nostra esistenza.
Poi c'è anche un altro problema,
è l'interconnettività, ovvero
possiamo accedere ad una quantità
abnorme di informazioni, senza precedenti,
e siamo tutti connessi,
non c'è più il vincolo di prossimità.
E poi c'è il progresso scientifico,
il progresso scientifico
che, per conto suo,
evolve ad una velocità senza precedenti
e, in qualche modo, ci spiazza,
modifica la nostra percezione
e la nostra società
e la nostra sfera cognitiva
di relazionamento con la realtà.
E poi, anche questa è stata utilizzata
come blasone,
un po' come fake news
dal giornalismo, non soltanto nostrano
ma internazionale,
l'analfabetismo funzionale,
ovvero l'incapacità di capire
quello che si legge.
Non è perché siamo scemi,
è semplicemente perché siamo bombardati
da informazioni.
Bombardati.
Calcolate che un'informazione
ha un periodo di durata per la fruizione
di circa due minuti,
il nostro cervello spanna
tra gli otto e i dodici secondi.
Prendiamo un'impressione,
collezioniamo l'informazione,
mettiamo tutto insieme,
e lo leghiamo ad uno strato emotivo
e quella diventa l'interpretazione.
Quello che abbiamo cercato di fare noi
da un punto di vista scientifico
è quello di preparare un esperimento
su grandi moli di dati,
uno su due milioni,
quasi tre milioni di persone
e un altro su 55 milioni di persone
e poi ne abbiamo fatto uno all'inizio
di quest'anno su 376 milioni di persone
per capire il rapporto dell'essere umano
con le narrazioni
che acquisisce sui social
e in particolare abbiamo preso
tutte le fonti
di informazione scientifiche
e tutte le fonti
di informazioni alternative,
complottiste.
Non abbiamo preso
la parte di nessuno dei due
perché la scienza evolve
ed è fatta da esseri umani
spesso e volentieri tira fuori
delle panzane mostruose,
dall'altra l'informazione alternativa
porta uno stato creativo
ma avendo fatto la lista
di tutte queste pagine
siamo andati a vedere come gli utenti
si relazionano
con queste diverse narrazioni,
la narrazione scientifica
e quella alternativa.
Viene fuori un risultato abbastanza banale
abbiamo rifatto i conti per questo grafico
almeno otto volte e li abbiamo mandati
anche a nostri colleghi all'estero
perché era troppo regolare.
O seguiamo fonti
di informazione scientifica,
o seguiamo fonti
di informazioni complottista.
In mezzo non c'è nessuno.
Ci sono giornalisti,
anche direttori di telegiornali
che continuano a dire
che lì in mezzo a quelle due curve
ci sia una grande quantità
di gente che non si esprime:
non è vero.
Pure il giornalista
ha bisogno delle fake news
per garantire il suo ruolo
Succede che siamo nel mondo
in cui il numero di like
che mettiamo su una specifica narrativa
influenza il numero di persone
da cui siamo circondati
che fanno la stessa cosa.
Ovvero, più sono attivo su una pagina,
più è alta la probabilità
che io sia circondato
nella mia sfera di amici su Facebook
su Facebook da persone che fanno
esattamente la stessa cosa:
se credo che il vaccino non vada erogato,
sarò circondato da persone
che supportano la mia visione del mondo
è chiamata "legge della
polarizzazione dei gruppi".
Due persone che sono accomunate
da una tesi
tenderanno ad essere più estreme
e a cercare conforto nel legame solidale
che esiste tra loro.
Questo crea quel fenomeno che è stato
in qualche modo pompato sui media
ormai è diventato di ordine pubblico:
le "Echo-Chambers", le casse di risonanza.
Ovvero possiamo accedere
ad un mare magnum di informazioni,
troviamo l'informazione
che più ci aggrada,
troviamo persone che sono simili a noi,
e insieme a loro costruiamo la narrazione.
Ma come reagiamo ad informazioni
che sono coerenti
con la nostra visione del mondo
ma contengono informazioni
palesemente false messe per scherzo?
Tipo, se credo
nella narrazione alternativa
e nella cura naturale, come reagirò
ad una informazione fatta apposta
che mi dice
che posso curare la
congiuntivite con il limone?
Oppure che all'interno delle scie chimiche
ci sia il viagra?
Queste informazioni vengono assorbite
dalla comunità che crede in una narrazione
nell'80 per cento dei casi.
Questo significa che un'informazione,
non importa se sia coerente o meno,
o vera o meno,
l'importante è che sostenga e supporti
la mia visione del mondo;
la mia narrazione, sia essa scientifica
sia essa complottista e alternativa.
E questo è un risultato invece
che ha fatto un impatto notevole
nell'ambito globale.
Come rispondono le persone ad informazioni
che sono a contrasto
con la loro visione del mondo?
Per esempio vado dal giornalista
e gli dico che dare
l'informazione corretta
non risolve il problema delle fake news.
Oppure vado da qualcuno
che crede nelle scie chimiche
e gli dico che non esistono.
Come reagisce? Ignora l'informazione.
Non la guarda neanche.
A quel punto, siamo andati a prendere
quei pochi esposti, dei 10 milioni
di persone
più o meno abbiamo
cinque mila interazioni effettive.
5000 utenti che hanno interagito;
di questi 5000 utenti che hanno interagito
con i post di debunking
come vengono chiamati,
il risultato è di rinforzo;
ovvero dopo l'esposizione
al post di debunking
saranno più attive nel consumare
informazione complottista.
Cercheranno conferme nel loro gruppo.
L'impatto è stato tale da far chiudere
la colonna del debunking
del Washington Post nel 2015,
siamo stati tradotti
in quasi tutte le lingue
e siamo finiti su Scientific American
anche se in Italia
per l'abilitazione scientifica nazionale
ancora queste cose non sono considerate
scienza d'impatto, ricerca d'impatto.
Samantha Power, ambasciatore statunitense
all'ONU,
alla Graduation Ceremony di Yale,
parla delle Echo-Chamber e dell'effetto
e identifica esattamente
il problema e la soluzione:
non dobbiamo parlare con qualcuno
perché dobbiamo convincerlo,
dobbiamo parlare con qualcuno
perché potrebbe aver ragione.
Potrebbe anche aver ragione.
Ritornare e restaurare il processo
della comunicazione.
A questo fine abbiamo aperto,
lanciato un'iniziativa
all'università Ca' Foscari
che ho avuto l'onore
di raggiungere da settembre,
quindi è un mese che son lì,
dove partiamo con Pandoors.
Pandoors, greco-inglese
per dire "tutte le porte",
è anche una nomenclatura
col vaso di Pandora
o Pandoro, a seconda
di come lo si vuol vedere
e l'idea è quella di creare sinergie
tra istituzioni, testate giornalistiche
e scienza
su una base che sia quantitativa,
che parta dall'umiltà
e non dalla speculazione
che tendenzialmente tende
a creare più fake news
che risposte sensate
a quello che succede.
Per esempio per quanto riguarda
la questione vaccinale,
perché non cerchiamo di capire
quali sono effettivamente
le resistenze delle persone
alla vaccinazione piuttosto che attaccarli
e dargli degli imbecilli
soltanto per corroborare il nostro ego?
Perché siamo diventati
molto narcisisti sui social.
Siamo diventati molto narcisisti
e per rompere il narcisismo
dobbiamo ritornare all'empatia,
imparare a comunicare,
capire che siamo tutti
figli della stessa scimmia.
Grazie.
(Applausi)